>>> SHOUIM
UPID A
PAY E J HE
FE  BIDEN'S BUSINESS
IN8
JUNCRES INVESTIGATH RGES ANDTO
CONFRONTUSINO GENERALLY AVOID
BRNG SENSITIVE
THE REPORT ALSO RIGHTLTST 'S ATS
FATHER IS
SIMILARLY,ANUARY 6th
AVE BEEN  OUT AADUT FORMER
DOJ ISE SIMILAY E
RELUCTANTO INDICTMENT TRIN
THIS ENVIRONMENT.
LO
IT'S WEIGHING ON MENT TO TA
TO MO THINK EITHER OR
BOTH OF THSES OUTABLED ARE MISRI
ACTUALLY THREE VERY
RE IN , TTORNEYS OT
TR  ERIC HOLDERIN 2E ELECTIONTT
THISAGRAPHIEALL VE
F
PRUTY L
INIGIMINALCHARRCEMENS MAY NEVESE
ADTO ACANDIDATE OR POLITICAL PAR
SUCH A PURPOSE IS INCONSISTENTWS
AGRAPH FORE DOESN'T THE RPRETARL
AVOI BY S N
EA, IT
DIRECTS ECUTOR NOT TG  I
PURPOSE OFFF AN
E IT O I GSIR S WHENREELECTION L
YOU'RE THKIF
CT
CANDIDATES.
STAFFER WITHOUT CLEARING OF ADIR
A WE RN, GE UNDERSTANDABLY THE
ELECTION.
BUCE PRECLUDHIS YEAR  HUNTER BIO
JUSTICE G POLITICAE ECEAD TH
THAT IAN
>> IT'S NOT IN BLACK,
TO SAY
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY WRITTEN THE,
UNAN S THAT ARE GOINGNE, KE EXEO
THEDSE IT COUL
CREATE AAP THAE NG TO
>> FOFHEI
T?
IN THAT MO
SCF SENGS WOULD  TN TOE EXAMPLE
SEITRSR THEY'RE ON AALLOT THIS
YEARALALVERT
INVESTIGATIVSTBEG
IT REALLY D
WHAT'S AN O
TRADITIONAL STT  FLABOR DAY WEEE
CAMPAIGN?
SOME OF THIS STUFF IS JUST NOT
D OUBE SPELLEDUT
OSRE IF O
MI
>> WELL, IDELIBERATELY NOT
FATHEY WANT TOPRECFLEXIBILIT CFE
VE FOR, EXECUTA
SECH                    RRT L S
THR RSND
ARRANT. THAT'S CONSOVERT IS WHEB
RIGHT? PUBLIE EXAMPLE,ERA LOT ON
SUBPNATO RSON'S ATTORMIBECAUSTHP
SO THAUL
INCTN.
REN S.
FIOUGHT. UST GOTOERE'S NO HAND
REG DA
THERE'S E THAT S
ER30-D A,
COULAP TRYIN  THNCI WILL JTI
AN APAN OF ION GOESUTRI AT ABOE
MAKI A
ONOUT RE ON.
APPEAR ON TH JUSTICE
R SHE IS
WIARD TO ETHICAL
AND MAYBTHGE>>HAA AUSE OWIE E WE
I THK YOUTORS HAVE TO WEIGH.
I THINRAN
ATAVIS
ENE REPUTATION OF
THMENT AND THE
FFICES
S.LK AE THATNG GREATER THA
THRE -- WE WER OF THAND , I K T
MONGDET
SEA MISSION THATOVAND OUTSID IT.
MAKES NSANT.
>>.TI LD OF BELIEVE.
EE AND TRUMP GTHISLD A
WHO IE -I'T YIH AN ORODY.
PUT THATCAUSE O ADDRNOO ASSERT D
COVERAGE, SEEMS LIKE THEY D WIT.
NOSAERE'S NCUTELICT
ATE
ABT AND THPO
THAT HGETS'T EER BIDEN W